bienvenue vous écoutez envergure est ici
on parle de tous les jeunes basketteurs
promis à un bel avenir que ce soit en
france en europe et aux états unis notre
credo on regarde beaucoup de matches
l'interview et on évalue ses prospects
sur notre site envergure point ces eaux
on a recensé plusieurs milliers de
joueurs avec évaluation écrite mais ici
à l'audio on va plutôt confrontés nos
opinions et donc on papote vous écoute
et de préférence avec notre site ouvert
à côté bon épisode à vous si c'est bien
beau négocié c'est très bien commenté et
si c'est génial partager
[Musique]
salut tout le monde nouvel épisode
d'envergure papa je suis avec alan et
ébène salut génial verts salue on parle
aujourd'hui de deux joueurs canadiens
qu'on a observés au championnat du monde
u19 cet été il s'agit de calais music
and et de bénédicte mathurin un petit
mot sur l'équipe canadienne qui arrivait
en a perdu en demi finale contre les usa
et qui a rappelé la médaille de bronze
contre la serbie une seule défaite den
usa militants dans le championnat au
mauvais moment
wiley mais je veux dire
c'était contre une très bonne équipe des
états unis
ce championnat l'as y ait quoi que ce
soit ça m'a beaucoup rassuré sur le
future reine du basket au canada c'est
encore on voit encore que les jeunes
sortent du lycée bataille pas avec les
mêmes armes que les jeunes américains 46
mois avec quelques années de retard à
cause du manque qu'un peu
d'infrastructures basketball dans le
coin ici mais on a des bons athlètes on
a des joueurs qui met beaucoup de
pression sur le panis puis moi j'ai eu
beaucoup de belles choses je te suis
totalement
on commence par le leader au scoring
d'études canadiennes kallie houston si
vous voulez bien
annan est ce que tu veux ou données
clients bien sûr donc près du stade ça
pas mal de temps qu'on entend par là à
vrai dire c'était on l'avait déjà vu
pour la première fois il avait joué au
but 16 armées du sénat américain il
avait vraiment mis beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de points beaucoup beaucoup de
paniers très rapidement ensuite il avait
annoncé son comique mènera michigan donc
il va jouer michigan cette année donc
avec une sous les ordres d'une joue à
world et il jouait dans la méga la méga
super team de monde hier dans depuis
deux saisons c'est à dire que je passe
chez nous et on a tous vu les graphiques
ou une année passée il ya quatre cadres
monde vertes qui sont faits draft
cas est unique à mauzé smodis cotisent
bornes et des recharges et le cinquième
de cinq de départ l'a décalé houston et
ensuite tous ces gars là sont partis aux
initiés et qu'elle est juste mais il est
resté pour cent sa dernière année au
lycée c'était le leader des aussi d'une
super team on avait créé un article avec
manu en mars je crois ou en avril sur le
retour de l'université entouré de deux
lycées ou gibson était le cas le
meilleur genre de manga vais renconter
ce tournoi c'est un scoreur grosse
coureurs qui est par nature plus plus il
a village tranquille à paris il n'a pas
les qualités athlétiques incroyable je
suis même parfois je trouve office un
peu de faux lent il est long mais il
s'est hissé à son âge dominé par le fait
qu il peut aller là où il veut et tirer
avec aise dans pas mal de positions ça
veut pas dire que c'est un profil plus
plus plus pour la nba ou faut que
physiquement être plus explosif mais ça
fait qu'à son âge et dans un tournoi
comme les u19 son bras a pu être mises
en valeur
il fait entre 2003 et 2005 selon les
mesures 93 kg ben il doit quelque chose
sur la présentation générale
non je pense qu'elle a vraiment bien
fait au sein joie que moi j'arrive ici
beaucoup j'ai un petit peu de difficulté
avec ses performances d'alda le 19 mai
il a fait
il a livré la marchandise qu'ils l'aient
fait de manière efficace ou non les
résultats et alors non juste avant de
continuer juste rappeler dans quel est
l'article on va parler vous avez écrit
avec manu sur le jean cau c'est comme ça
qu'on dit le capitole de gaikai qu est
la langue la un article d'antoine
bérenger sur les u16
2019 avec un
tournoi où il y avait beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de joueurs de team usa seront
les têtes d'affiché de la prochaine
draft
challenger n adrian griffin jabbari
smith et tout ça est qu un épiphénomène
ou verdi n'ont pas de quoi lui n'était
pas dans l'équipe d'allan 16 mai
qui avait vu ça a été le déjà le leader
de timika d'assaut côté de chez des
chats qui est aussi un énorme prospects
adieu donc on lire
dans l'article d'antoine
17 points par match 35 % aux shoots sur
le tournoi 19% à 3 points ben qu'est ce
qu'on a vu offensivement de
qu'elle aimait il y avait ce qu'on
appelle un timide greenrights la y avait
le feu vert de la cedh
quand ils voulaient comment il voulait
piste un peu ce qui a fait pendant tout
le tournoi c'était portes boro mais on
sentait qu'il y avait une espèce de 2
pas de méprise de pour la compétition
mais il ya bien sûr vont avoir leur
affaire qui avait absolument besoin de
rien ni personne
ça a rendu la vie de certains de ses
coéquipiers un peu compliqué je pense au
camp qui ya joué avec qualifié maxence
prospère
transpass un peu trop où se placer sur
le pen un cahier tél parce que justement
il était un peu juste en était un peu
partout sur le terrain mais
mais c'est ça sinon
j'ai besoin de revendications qui
sont son nom ça brise décision était
même facteur là ils prenaient tous les
lancers et walter partout qui - je suis
d'accord qu'il livrer la marchandise
mais moi je me déteste ou france est
championne et
17 shoots par match
oui et puis c'est pour nos pires voter
il faut pour les gens à la maison les
matchs durent moins longtemps possible
on comprend moins de shoots en général
oui alan way
e
est ce qu'on va en réalité si on était
sûr le saoût
sur le tir bas
pour moi je vais pour les personnages à
3par fait pas son niveau d'hier sur un
tournoi il a 11 sur 58 19 % qu'elle est
due cette année pour un genre qui vaut
pour cent à 3 points le 22 sur 26 aux
lancers francs est là pour le prouver et
c'est dès ses matches à mondevert d'une
amp assez longue durée c'est pour moi le
foot c'est sa carte d'entrée au scoring
dans le monde professionnel juste là bon
il a eu il ya eu des gros gros trou
d'air tu fais sur un sur un échantillon
de sept matchs tu fais un stups est un 1
sur 10 1 0 sur 8 1 1 sur 7 et 1 1 sur 8
bah voilà
ça te plante complètement
mais ça pour moi c'est un bon tireur
20h01 tireur
diversifiée il peut tirer dans plusieurs
positions dans plusieurs types d'actions
il n'y a pas un énorme effort des jambes
c'est beaucoup dans le bras
mais je pense que le tir c'est loin
d'être un mac et son principal sur
lequel est du stade même pour moi une de
ses forces principales comme quoi elle
il faut entre les boks corps les
statistiques et puisqu'on peut revoir
visuellement change en fait voilà vous
je te poser la question pour décrire un
peu son fils et sa part vite et en fait
même s'ils savaient pas forcément où on
avait l'impression qu'ils pouvaient
rentrer tout ça que je dis ouais je suis
d'accord que c'est pas la technique qui
est le problème c'est la prise de
décision là
oui c'est tous les ans perdent est très
compliquée en apprenez super compliqué
baïse à tous prix
les autres ce prix a pris préféré c'est
ce qui m'énerve un peu il préfère
apprendre compliqué plutôt que prendre
une seconde voire ancien coéquipier qui
s'était dit souvent il ya bien qu
explique italie parce qu'ils la gagnent
c'est apprendre à dole souvent on parle
autant droit
et au niveau de son d'autres choses de
son jeu de création
ce qu'on le voit quand même il est
capable de faire de prendre les bonnes
décisions quand même au niveau de la
passe
bien sûr
moi j'aime moi j'aime bien ce beauté de
lui moi si je suis une équipe en billets
c'est sûr que je regarde d'abord à quel
point on peut extrapoler sa création
parce qu'il n'a pas fait qu'il n'a pas
montré qu'il peut pas le faire déjà il a
17 passes décisives c'est pas affreux
franchement bon c'est pas c'est à dire
qu'il a quand même il avait pas vu de
l'importance dans la terrasse ombragée
bien et je les bien aimés sur pick'n
roll et puis en réalité c'est par si
c'est du fait du contexte qu'ils étaient
dans cette situation là parce que la
haine et marne le petit meneur donc
l'optique le petit frère d'andré neymar
de niagha
qui est aussi un joueur avec qui il a
joué à au lycée qui a un prospect qui va
jouer à créer toit de l'an prochain avec
toute la création en en main donc il
peut créer moi je pense que c'est plus
un tireur qu'un créateur pour le moment
mais c'est pas un trou noir c'est un
genre que poser la balle c'est un joueur
qui a une bonne vision du jeu voilà
oui puis je disais comme comme tu l'a
mentionné à la non l'offre on le fait
jouer en pick and rolls que ce que je
pense que j'ai beaucoup apprécié du
à travers votre
jouet à cork à tout le monde ap cannes
au parlement pendant le tournoi c'est
qu'il attire la défense se veut dire une
cavité offensive absolument incroyable
ça ça peut lui ça lui permet de
seulement de libérer ses coéquipiers
lorsqu'il trois passes décisives par
match merci c'est pas mauvais du tout
pour une livre mais pendant ces sorties
cinq des sept matches qui fait 3 passes
donc c'est vraiment pas mal
parce que comme tu dis c'est pour un
athlète incroyable pour les billets donc
je pense que je serai au chômage sont là
mais on va passer par la création
même si il a montré quelques dragons
mais ce document d'explosion
du haut niveau on s'interrogera pas
qu'ils avaient l'air de gala contre
certaines équipes
étaient faussés par le moc par le manque
de
potentiel entre les équipes
moi je pense que physiquement c'est il
manque d'explosivité pour le niveau du
top niveau une bille et pourquoi on
qu'on se le dise si mais c'est un mais
il ya un vrai bras et un bon quid donc
il ya d'autres qualités mais comme le
dit ben si on veut lui donner la balle
en nba alors qu'ils puissent passer
parce qu'il pourra pas nous battre tous
temps les visas vis sur le premier pas
ou alors il se sera vraiment le
prototype du hac il va devoir mettre que
des tirs super complexe où vivre
offensivement et c'est super complexe de
vivre sur les tirs très compliqué
et indépendant m mode chez les pros
souhaite c'est qu'on met en avant ses
sites arrivent à créer beaucoup de tirs
faciles bas c'est vous bien pour ta
production si tu mets beaucoup de tirs
complique alors tu les mets c'est bien
mais donc au niveau i n'diaye sera
publié
et du coup son prend pour pour la
projection il est dit que c'est un
ailier on on le voit jouer tous
liés en nba ou plutôt un tuto arrière
quand plutôt porteur du ballon gombert
poste à quatre avec un peu de création
je pense post 4 way où il payé trop il
est trop grave il va devenir trop gros
pour l'appuyer pas assez rapides et
profonds et trop non plus
le floor qui s'est pas plaint oum et
clairement il fait quoi et
505 kg
non non non c'est mémé calculations et à
91 ans wes 90 92 jours et 10 heures je
pensais je pensais de sa liste qui l'ont
laissée par ce poste
là désolé le mama canadienne s'est
montrée
donc pas ce qui est du coup alors c'est
ses atouts physiques en est ce que ça
lui sert en défense quoi qui
ce que j'ai vu cinq à appliquer quoi
mais je vais surtout alors moi je vais
dans les matches que j'ai vus j'étais
surtout vous défendre au bol
je les trouvais appliquée
bon voila il prend des rebonds moi je
les prenais le bon en défense comme il
s'implique là non
son intelligence offensif se répercute
défensivement mais
il pourra jamais défendre le meilleur
ailier adversaires bien parce qu'il
pourra pas tenir sur l'explosivité et
physique
et je pense que ce qu'on a vu dans l'ue
19 quoi être faux c'est justement parce
que le niveau à 7 sec était ton travail
plus bas ou parce que ce latéral
m'empare loin ils vont avec francky
améliorant son explosivité il faut
ça sera pas une énorme défense à ce que
ce soit un défenseur correct mais sera
jamais une énorme défense en
rond c'est intéressant juste pour
rebondir si siemens visualise au poste
là a pu tellement de post 4 mais là le
poste faut revoir donc trois quatre
voire six tirs au temps et qui tient
bien pour l'espé signe d'une équipe en
fait eh ben c'est pas si grave s'il
n'est pas al sisi fort que ça on se
réunit notamment parce qu'il va t'aider
pour ton spéciaux oui oui
on voit tous d'ailleurs on a tous envie
que les joueurs pour draft réaux soient
tous des porteurs de bois et tout ça
mais si ce jour-là est bon défensivement
fait les bons choix quand on lui demande
sur une route entre porteurs de badges
secondaire ou tertiaire et est capable
de prendre beaucoup de tirs à trois
points et d'omettre à une bonne réussite
ce sera un joueur super intéressant pour
une franchise
oui mais c'est ça ça va ça va ça va
dicter un peu ouest qui va tomber dans
la draft d'envoi tous avoir été un peu
c'est parce qu'un important à laval
empêche d'un point puis c'est ça je suis
un shooteur à vue il va tomber dans une
équipe qui a des choses le reportant le
bal puis qui vont ils voient ils pas se
glisser dans le rôle complémentaire
moi ce que j'ai vu au niveau qu'on donne
son caractère c'est que il était
commandeur
il a parlé quoi il aime bien parler
inséré or c'est là ils se cachent pas
quand il faut aller défendre ses potes
il a pas l'air comme ça parce que ça a
l'air d'être un gain façon de
visuellement ça d'être un type gentil
qui prend ses shoots dans les points en
tête quand il faut y aller légal il a
parlé à ses coéquipiers aussi beaucoup
c'est ce que j'aime c'est quelque chose
que j'aimerais c'est que la leadership
parce que dans cette équipe canadienne
live pour beaucoup de gens qui parlaient
à peu près lui paiera rien d'amoral
c'est à peu près tout
mais c'est assez intéressant aussi parce
que on l'a vu dans 2 on a vu dans des
situations pas sa diversité parce que
vraiment vert dans réalité et qui peut
être trop forte
c'est trop facile mais là on l'a vu ou
pas des fois il était pâle mais il
n'était pas le meilleur joueur sur le
terrain ils n'avaient pas la meilleure
équipe sur le terrain et ça c'est
intéressant parce que dans le match
continue et c'est même s'ils gagnent pas
la demie il met des gros tirs dans la
deuxième mi temps et laisser un peu de
faire revenir son équipe et c'est
intéressant parce que la bande verte il
était trop trop fort mais vraiment donc
là c'était un signe un contexte
différents contextes différents
collectifs mais aussi un contexte
psychologique qu'ils étaient différents
ouais c'est clairement un compétiteur
moi j'aime ce côté là chez lui
est ce que l'on nous sommes directe est
que son compère deux ailiers bénédicte
mature maintenant mais registre on peut
dire qu'il va jouer au michigan
j'attends de voir comment va le faire
jouer c'est une grosse recrue c'est une
des plus grosses que kruger amène juwan
howard depuis qu'il a pris en main le
programme
et qu'elle est qu'il ya michigan car pas
mal de joueurs
comment il va utiliser comme le dit weis
qui va avoir de la création à faire mais
ça va être très intéressant parce que
c'est un bon programme 100 grammes qui
joue bien certains cas amener en france
rac noordin top 10 l'an passé donc
très très intéressant en ce sens moi je
suis très curieux étant donné son som
ses dimensions un peu explique si elle
est tendue disons qu'il y ait montré
qu'ils étaient capables d'être un
créateur sûr
si on peut l'utiliser en poste 5 ans
porte sur cinq dans les petits
alignement ce genre de remettre cinq
gars qui couvrent sur le thème
sosa ce que fait une utilisation
créative de chances qu'ils se trouvent
avant parce qu'ils ont dit qu'ils ne
sonne et puis ils ont repris là aussi
recruter moussa diabaté le français
qu'est qui va à mj est qui qui est en
poste 4-5 dans toi est ce que mon point
là on sait que c'est des gros bonhommes
absolument s'ouvrir
rétréci en argument disons parce que mon
équipe qui est en fait de deux trains
côté vitesse moi je trouve ce jour à qui
ce qui peut entraîner derrière ça a
essayé en poste si tu veux faire du
spread pick and roll et puis avoir un
bon gros spécimens complètement exacte
barça on va suivre ça de pris
l'année prochaine pendant quelques noms
ses courses dans trois semaines ouais
c'est ça j'aime pas quand on attaque on
attaque de mathurin ouais bah oui parce
qu'en plus tu connais bien il est dans
ta zone donc
en nylon boy là c'est le futur du québec
magnifique ben tu tu nous lance sur sur
qui et qui est in qu'on veut semble-t-il
si on le connaît déjà
bénédicte mature et arrière slash est
liée à une zone à ce format requis à 19
heures
on appelle ça un anglais l'impression
qu'ils jouent les deux positions sans
vraiment être au problème
vient d'une famille de sportifs un jouet
a fait du sport toute sa vie il était
carré
avec une intelligence
qi un potentiel de 2 cuill élevé sur le
terrain gros
gros professé c'est certes c'est de
mettre un jeu coin il ya de m en tout 90
kg 90 kg il est énorme pour sa position
il n'y a pas eu la pole un exposé sur le
terrain mais il est vraiment cessé comme
de ce que tu qualifies info
l'instant nous sommes les plus
influentes pâturant pour moi puis puis
moins insolites comme sur la vie comme
sur la ligue
mais même est capable de battre son
homme aux premiers pas en le contrôle il
a fait son nom a
acquise aux notes comme étant le gac qui
attaquent le panier vraiment de manière
à créer
très agressif il n'y a pas beaucoup de
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'il ya
pas beaucoup de lancers francs par match
mais souvent lorsqu'ils attaquent le
panier les adversaires sont censés
prendre une décision d'affaires et
décide de se tasser le laisser ou
marquer ou
où il ya pas beaucoup il n'a pas cherché
beaucoup de contacts parce que souvent
il ya pour personne qui sera au panier
sur spéciaux vraiment très intéressant
chez lui donc
physiquement ce que je vois qui est très
très emmerdant l'affronter et monsieur
s'est développé un tir à trois points
pendant la nuit qui leur montrer où le
19 qui vont avec lesquels ils m'ont fait
une très belle constance sur le 19
un an un jeu de pollock absolument
respectable
mais c'est ça le tout le monde croyait
que bénédicte nature à les déclarer à la
draft parce qu'on l'attendait pape ait
au moins trois mêlées va tourner la
grosse question maintenant qu'il y ait
tous les scalps j'en ai parlé avec
robert un ancien de nba draft twitter
qui en disent qu'ils travaillent je
crois pour sacramento maintenant la
question sur les lèvres de tous les cas
les risques génétiques mathurin est ce
qu'on peut lui donner le ballon pour
orchestrer la tacc d'une équipe et c'est
la grosse question qui l'attend cette
ânerie pluie c'est une question à
laquelle il n'a pas répondu par adulte 9
oui c'est ça qu'ils étaient alignés avec
le thème contes dont on aime parler même
barbe même bâti pour dire qu'ils
monopolisent beaucoup de ballons qui
aime quand il veut aussi beaucoup shoots
faciles et martin de loin
et il aime bien porter le ballon et en
fait ce qu'on a vu au niveau de la
création pour natura c'est quand les
deux étaient houston et même par d'été
sur le banc quoi et
on est un peu resté sur notre faim on
peut le dire
alan dont on dérange moi je m'attende
personnellement je m'attendais à
vous attendez ces moments là où il a
démontré un petit peu ce qu'ils
pouvaient faire balle en main et la
distribution et on n'a pas vu grand
chose on
bah moi je me rends en fait c'était
c'était parce que j'attendais donc j'ai
pas été trop déçu mais parce que pour
moi il n'a pas encore le trollage les
programmes encore de lien intelligent
mais il trouve encore procès faire le
process
d'après ans sont
collectives pour jouer aux tensions
pitié drôle et comme de quoi je mettais
beaucoup en passe de pick and roll eh
ben ils étaient ils étaient un peu
n'était pas extrêmement à l'aise et puis
je pensais que un contexte egypte qui
viennent le canada avec 26 scoring bull
elle vient de ces coupes avaient besoin
de s'ébattre sa 200e tir à trois points
et d'une agressivité vers le cercle en
transition tu peux pas tout faire non
plus et alors oui mais qui sont justes
et puis j'ai aussi l'impression
j'ai pas regardé vous regardez les
utiliser et j'ai l'impression qu'il y
avait quasiment soit neymar de soyaux
stamm tous quasiment tout le temps sur
le terrain en vrai
vide et si tu veux il y avait des
moments où nous sommes sous que c'était
plutôt moins les deux parties et
soutient
l'asie donc dans la bonne base c'est
qu'ils créent maintenant et mais c'était
basé pour secouer lui mais c'était plus
basiques pour attaquer le cercle phase i
pour aller au cercle et c'est un peu
normal c'est un c'est un jour qui alors
c'est un 2002 donc il est jeune il avait
un rôle même si alors c'est un peu la
communauté analytics grave qu'il aimait
beaucoup d'en passer parce qu'il avait
un rôle secondaire un mari zona
vous voyez des choses on voyait des
outils physique on voyait plein de
choses extrêmement intéressante mais
dans le rôle d'importance offensive ils
n'étaient pas primaire donc je pense que
ça va aller en s'accentuant
tranquillement et bah c'est un peu comme
houston
les
italiens avec 13 passes décisives entre
198 minutes hyper 15 ballons donc le
ratio est négatif mais à cet âge là faut
toujours qu'on dirait surtout les
petites compétitions
donc j'attendais pas énormément donc moi
je n'ai pas été trop trop déçu parce que
je pense que les jeunes et que sa force
d'abord c'est d'être un je pense
défenseur tenace
jorky dont il faut qu'il progresse au
tiers comme ça on va lui on va voir que
les arbres on le respectera ils se font
à klose à hautefort pour soutenir pour
imposer là-bas les attaquer le cercle 31
sur 30 et 25 sur 31 aux lancers francs
c'est un style cellule la stat que je
retiens son tournoi
80% dans ces prends pour moi c'est
c'était le plus important
le tir est quand même bien en place un
doute vous et moi ce que j'ai aimé aussi
c'est quand il prend 6 août face à son
adversaire et il a une telle puissance
dans les gens qu'il est capable de bien
sûr n'importe qui même contre les états
unis
contre des défenseurs costaud et
puissant peut-être comme lui on les
applique ses soutes il n'est jamais lui
pardonner prendre de se lever
c'est je pense que nous avons aimés et
une en parler je pense dans son article
sur les arrières ailiers guarda à voir
c'est un des joueurs dont on attend le
plus leur tour une cible pour la
prochaine au web aux ligaments
et son tournoi va dans ce sens là il a
fait son temps et peut-être des semences
si on attendait son tournoi est décevant
si on attend que ça attendez de voir de
la création de pick and roll a avancé et
tout ça mais si b indique mathurin et ça
a des limites voilà qu'en course pointe
lottery pick fatale pour est entre 12 et
18 c'est déjà le secteur progresse déjà
qu'ils se tapent ville qui vous allez il
faut ce qui montre que son tir n'était
pas juste bonjour le chien n'était pas
juste un
feu de paille parce que les statistiques
au tiers de son année fraîchement et son
exceptionnelle mais là qui remonte qu'il
est capable de faire du bonbon lancers
francs sur 7 matchs et puis les diables
de mètres et de prendre des tirs
compliqué pas juste en spots up cette
progression est linéaire il progresse de
ça je trouve que ça se voit qu'ils
progressent de mois en mois
donc c'est positif
on parle rapidement de sa finition au
cercle
[Musique]
je n'ai pu donc comme je disais banny
passe n'importe quoi j'ai l'impression
qui peut passer n'importe qui avec sa
puissance et son premier pas
après il a tendance trouve à s'écraser
un petit peu sur les grands 1 n'a pas
trouvé forcément la solution près du
cher même si fini avec à 2 points 1 57%
donc il n'ya pas une impulsion verticale
incroyable c'est une des choses que je
crois le pays il est très bon avec le
contrôle de son corps dans les allées
crabe de prendre des décisions dans les
airs mais côté ou verticalité
d'accord je travaillais pas il y aura
beaucoup d'espacé pour être capable de
sauter très haut
ben tu nous as dit en plein ce que tu
pensais de cette défense que j'aimerais
bien entendre puisque la turquie
l'attendait comme un groupe défenseur
ben
lorsqu'il est lorsqu il est impliqué
dans le match personnellement il
pourrait un énorme défenseur pour
arrêter à peu près n'importe qui par
totalement gros grêlons que les joies
les variables des autres équipes ont
vraiment des difficultés à le battre
mais pendant les u19 c'était c'était cet
été revient repos là le prendre au
sérieux n'était pas juste pas une
question de deux genoux d'articulation
mais y était et est tout droit comme un
pic
il se fait battre à gauche se battre à
droite
bat sur les écrans ça faisait c'était
très très difficile à regarder condé
équipe facile aussi quand le japon quant
à lituanie
même toit quand qu'il s'était d'image
avec des plus hauts des clauses attentes
comme avec les états unis la
longue vue
mathieu bénédicte masri on ne sont pas
tes anciennes en défensive
alain tu rajoutes moi je suis séparé
j'étais un petit j y avait des hauts et
des bas quoi il était capable de d'être
très fort sur l'homme et puis parfois
ils étaient
n'étaient pas concentrés en défense la
nive au blocage qu'il était complètement
dans les choux
j'ai réalisé le match contre la lituanie
ce que c'est je pense sur le compte moi
personnellement je trouve que les deux
joueurs des fonds dépend en fait donc au
bout d'un an jean à wimereux en revient
au staff je pense que c'est un coach
vient de connaître beaucoup beaucoup
mieux que moi je ne connais pas mais
c'est un coach est vrai que c'est un
coach lancé le coach canadien et la
floride c'est un nouveau c'est un
nouveau coach aussi que je sais pas à
quel point l école très au sérieux
mais en tout cas il
moi je pense que mathurin délaissé de
responsabilités offensives pour à ce
focus et être un très bon défenseur sur
l'homme parfois ils com - wendel a dit
la ilaha illallah les outils donc si on
lui demande bah moi peut-être de jouer -
il veut pas mal à part le match contre
le compteur porto rico il joue pas plus
de 24 minutes tous les matches et a pris
80 tirs en sept matches
donc il n'avait pas de responsabilité
je dis pas que son rôle était primaire
et qu'il devait tout en attaque et donc
il n'avait pas besoin de défendre mais
qui jusque
lorsque avec un rôle plus
s'il est il a moins de responsabilités
offensives qui met dedans qu'il ya un
rôle de cooper horse ball et de
shooter est bien là il pourra vraiment
être encore plus intéressant est
impliqué défensivement
qui sur le caractère du bonhomme
est-ce que c'est à dire non à reasoner
et au début de la saison dernière
j'ai trouvé garé veux je pense que vous
avez dit ça
papa forcément content de ski copains
ils expriment beaucoup de choses quand
il n'était pas content de ce qui faisait
quand il était content quand il est des
frustrés on voyait tout ça là aux u19 on
l'a vu se prendre le bec avec ses
adversaires aussi gros gros caractères
wii vient d'un milieu comme ça aussi il
vient d'une équipe vraiment
d'une équipe ou lycée beau lycée où l
école secondaire canadienne qui était
vrai
cette optique là c'est vraiment
quelqu'un qui a vécu beaucoup de choses
aussi il ya une série de son grand frère
est décédé
donc il ya beaucoup de bagages il joue
avec une belle énergie mais je crois que
c'est un peu la folie pas d'endroit la
canalise
peut-être un peu mieux s'il veut durer
lâcher les
progrès qui ne donne rien ok
on a fait le tour
pour les deux prospects c'est bon ouais
moi je crois que je tape mon frère je
crois que
s'il peut montrer ne serait ce qu'un peu
de création cette année à une zone à il
va
être empêchés dans la loterie le genre
13e ou quelque chose du genre
tu vois si ou trois
bons et parce qu'il fait beaucoup
beaucoup de choses offensivement parlant
trucs beaucoup de choses régnier
ok ah nan tu dois y est si tu vois si
aussi jeu c'est pareil pour que je suis
en train de laisser deux champions de
voir à pas mal de films 2d prochain
freshman et donc j'essaie va jeter c'est
rétablir un big bang du tort mais oui je
pense qu'ils dominent dans mon pré
saison dans la pré saison il sera dans
le monde dans un tiers qui ira entre 15
et 30 donc il sera dans cette zone là
tout se passe bien et sera il se rend au
dit hier
ok mais je crois qu'on a fini notre
épisode dégâts merci ben merci à l'âne
épisode
[Musique]
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner pour
recevoir la notification
[Musique]